yeah just because i'm decent at scrabble
doesn't it doesn't make me a good rapper
but i do admire the word play element
it's just a musical component and
finding the flow it would be very
difficult
okay playing virgo
all i want is a potato
hey it's my first potato ah
it's a potato opening
this is what i've been waiting for
i didn't even have to go to
idaho
[Music]
okay now what do i do with my potato
i guess i have to become a potato farmer
now
so i'll show this after the game but lee
chess classifies
this exact position as a potato you can
exchange coaching sessions with harry
mack you teach him chess he teaches you
rap yes so quack
someday i'll rap about quacking and
potatoes and tomatoes
and tornadoes
what else rhymes
with potato
nato
okay
i will say this is a little bit outside
my comfort zone
but i think when you
when you play the potato you have to
act like a potato
so the question to ask yourself is what
would the potato do
the key to beat boxing is to not be
worried about making stupid sounds for
about six months you go t h b t b to b t
patooi for a while but you eventually
get better and can show other people oh
i appreciate the
advice
no one's ever like given me tips on how
to beatbox
so i guess that's my first beatboxing
lesson
thp tbtbt pitui okay
i'll keep that in mind for the next time
i try and beatbox
okay
getting swole
do i even rook lift bro
potatoes are very versatile
are they vegetables
wait what is a potato
it's not an animal it's either a
vegetable or um
probably not a fruit it's a starch oh a
starch
legume no
i mean there is there's sweet potato
there's baked potato
[Music]
there's
boiled potato
couch potato
can you explain a rook lift
a rook lift is when you
lift a rook
and then move it over
so usually it's it's up and then over
also called a rover
what is chat saying
fried liver potato
potatoes are mammals potatoes are from
south america
[Music]
i don't know who or what to believe
okay
i'm gonna have a pawn on b6 soon
i feel like i'm planting a potato in
black's position
[Music]
and then it's going to grow into a
beautiful potato tree
i don't think that's how potatoes work
though
uh oh
my rooks are taking away the squares my
knight can move
uh thankfully i have g5 so
i'm not dead yet
i have to play knight g5
and h6 oh actually after each six uh the
knight's safe
because the rook pins the thing
why is everyone talking about me
uh it's potato
potato
or potato pea
yeah this is my first potato opening
potato potato
what do i do here
i could play um
play a bishop move
i can play queen a1
it's kind of neat
can i explain rook g1 i i had some idea
of playing g4
but my idea no longer makes any sense
and it didn't really make sense to begin
with so
what to do
yeah i think there's there's gonna be a
decent amount of ways black can try and
punish me
then again
how do you punish a potato
i feel like potatoes are unpunishable
foods
like you can try and eat the potato
just have to make sure i have thick
potato skin
yeah it's probably one of the best
potato type foods
oh there's also mashed potatoes hash
browns
tater tots
what is this position
this is a terrible position
i have to play king baxter e1 i think
i don't feel good about this
it's as if i overdosed on potato
calculating this move
i'll play this move
yeah there should be one with hang the
knight
it's my first game against this opponent
too
they probably think i'm an overrated i
am
okay now my knight's actually hanging
but it's still interesting because i
have e4
and then things get really weird
like weirder than they already are
i have queen c1 here
all right knight's attack but this
night's also attacked
and my pawn is still chilling
someday this pond is it's going to turn
into a potato tree
oh a boss a says i have my first series
tournament today
the question is can you share how do you
approach them
how do you prepare it when it's
impossible to know your next opponent
number one don't play the potato
um
[Music]
but yeah on the more serious note if you
have like a tournament coming up
your first serious tournament
don't worry too much about specific
preparation against your opponents
it's more about
trying to find your optimal mental form
um
your games won't be decided
at least most of your games won't be
decided in the opening
and you just want to make sure you're as
focused
and as mentally sharp as possible
make sure you're eating well sleeping
well
get some fresh air some exercise between
games
helps to have a balanced diet
and don't eat too many potatoes
how am i not down any material
also my rooks on e3
oh this rook just migrated went from
here to here
uh i'm thinking g
g4
and g4 is kind of interesting
the position is still not great but it's
better than it was earlier
okay i'm going to play this move
also sometimes depends how long you have
to prepare for a tournament
if you have several weeks
then it can help to like
to review your opening wrapper tour
ahead of time play some training
games do regular tactics if you only
have a few days you just want to
[Music]
try and minimize as many distractions as
possible
and then don't
don't burn yourself out with studying
beforehand
i want to play g5 here
looks kind of nice
now my pieces are kind of making sense
and this rook went from here to here to
here to here to here
it might land on g5
there once was a man who drank tea who
gave his stream a guarantee pawns he
would give up his opponent's king would
often be struck quack quack quack like a
duck
[Music]
oh man
thank you miats
subbing for 28 months
i think black's already like under a lot
of pressure here because b7 is hanging
after it takes takes i'm threatening not
only to take on b7
but also to unleash the thing and then
attack the rook
c5 is tender
oh h5 was played
uh
i have g6 here now
yeah i guess the key to making potatoes
is to plant multiple potato trees
and then if one of them dies other one
will hopefully grow
yeah my expectations were not high for
that limerick
i liked the finish quack quack quack
like a duck
okay
oh
i'll take with you
for the notification gang imrozen let's
go let's go you're just in time though
you're just in time for a potato feast
so i could take the rook but even more
delicious
is taking the pawn
and black can't stop meat
the potato is too powerful
[Music]
what other vegetable openings are there
i don't think there's any other openings
named after vegetables
yet
yeah i guess black can give a spike
check and then another spike check
and then the third spike check but
it's inevitable
potato op yeah
[Music]
thanks for the game raju
i'm sorry you had to
face a potato
so just to show
the potato i wasn't lying
this is called the potato
i don't know what the history of the
opening also moo also oink
also nay also core also ba
also meow also woof
and that will be the finished of the
youtube video
i've always wanted to make a youtube
video that's just called potato
and then just to have a big potato is a
thumbnail